dans quelques jours le domaine de
villandry sortira de sa torpeur
les 16 états de jardins et de forêts
retrouverons leur vocation de haut lieu
touristique qui séduit tant les
visiteurs les mois d'inactivité ont été
terribles pour les finances avec un
chiffre d'affaires divisé par deux et
plus de 2 millions d'euros de manque à
gagner
chômage partiel pour les jardiniers
réduction des charges
tout a été étudié méthodiquement pour
limiter les dépenses
il a fallu faire des accalmies surtout
vraiment tous les registres j'ai passé
en revue toutes nos sources de dépenses
et finalement à la fois l'électricité
l'énergie le gaz des fournitures de
bureau les déplacements la promotion on
a vraiment était
à des dépenses minimaliste seuls les
jardins rouvriront leurs portes
le château quant à lui restera fermé des
sens de circulation canaliseront les
visiteurs qui pourront de nouveau
arpenté ce joyau des jardins à la
française
les dix jardiniers vont pouvoir
reprendre du service à plein temps sous
les serres certains d'entre eux
préparent les semis pour de futurs
plantes qui garniront les parterres de
couleurs et l'enthousiasmé déjà palpable
ça fait du bien de voir un petit peu de
demande surtout aux visiteurs quand il
veut tellement heureux ils ont les yeux
tellement jardin est magnifique en fait
donc quoi c'est vraiment un plaisir de
les voir revenir réellement way à cette
période de printemps avec toutes les
fleurs qui vont arriver
c'est vraiment le pont à villandry n'a
pas perdu de sa superbe pendant ces huit
mois de sommeil
les travaux sont même allés bon train
cent mille nouveaux bus ont été plantés
pour régénérer les haies
en quelques mois le domaine mondialement
connue devrait retrouver ses 350 mille
visiteurs annuels